Caroline Forsters Welt
sind Stickereien.
Mit ihnen erobert sie die Welt.
Hans Rudolf Herren
hat mit einer Wespe
das Leben
von Millionen Menschen gerettet.
Und Hoteldirektor Simon Rindlisbacher
schwört in Asien
auf Schweizer Qualität.
Sie erzählen "Schweizer
Erfolgsgeschichten - grenzenlos gut".
* Ruhige, fernöstliche Lautenklänge *
In der vietnamesischen Hauptstadt
Hanoi
führt ein Schweizer
eines der grossen Fünfsternehotels.
Doch Simon Rindlisbacher
ist im Krisenmodus.
Vincent, ich sehe gerade:
Die Qatar Airways ist zurück,
aber wir sind voll heute.
Alle sollten ein Zimmer bekommen,
aber wir haben nicht genug.
Sie müssen sich die Zimmer teilen.
- Ja, aber sie wollen nicht.
Sie wollen das nicht?
Die Cabin Crew ist einverstanden,
aber die Piloten nicht.
Dann machen wir es so:
Als Erstes gibst du dem Captain,
dem Co-Piloten
und dem Maitre de Cabine ein Zimmer.
Damit sie sich zurückziehen können.
Für die anderen
finden wir eine Lösung.
Das ist ein kleines Problem.
Der Flug wurde annulliert.
Jetzt müssen sie sich
12 Std. ausruhen können.
Wir müssen die Zimmer zurücknehmen,
aber wir sind voll heute Nacht.
Sie ärgern sich natürlich,
dass wir keine Zimmer haben.
Aber wir waren nicht auf
eine Flugannullierung vorbereitet.
Simon Rindlisbacher war schon
als Sekundarschüler in Gossau
von Anzug und Fliege fasziniert.
Nach der Hotelfachschule brachte er
den Glanz der Schweizer Hotellerie
erst nach Bangkok
und später nach Hanoi.
Wir schleichen kurz durch die Lobby.
Um zu schauen,
ob das mit Qatar klappt.
Falls die gestrandete Crew
keine Zimmer bekommt,
muss sie in einem anderen Hotel
untergebracht werden.
Das ist für Rindlisbacher
mit hohen Kosten verbunden.
Sind sie okay?
- Ja.
Wir haben fünf Zimmer.
Die beiden Piloten
und drei Ladys bleiben hier,
die andern gehen ins Fortune Hotel.
Perfekt, danke. Bis später.
Es ist etwas doof,
ich mache das nicht gern.
Hanoi ist heute recht gut besetzt.
Sie wollen natürlich Geld machen
mit unseren Gästen.
Das muss ich selbst zahlen.
Wenn wir überbucht sind,
geht das nicht anders.
* Ruhige, fernöstliche Lautenklänge *
Für Hoteldirektor Rindlisbacher
ist die Bettenauslastung
auch Gradmesser seines Erfolgs.
Gestern haben wir es
nicht ganz geschafft -
wir haben
ein Zimmer zu wenig verkauft.
Jetzt müssen wir rausfinden,
was gestern passiert ist.
Wir mussten die Crew wegschicken
und jetzt ist doch nicht
100 % abgeschlossen - nicht gut.
Ich konkurriere etwas
mit meinem Freund von Mövenpick.
Der hatte letzte Nacht 100 % -
der lacht jetzt natürlich.
Und ich habe ein Zimmer
zu wenig verkauft.
Aber ich lache an anderen Tagen,
das ist okay.
Wir haben eine gesunde Konkurrenz.
Der Stickerei-Boom Ende des 19. Jh.
machte St. Gallen
zu einer wohlhabenden Stadt.
Kommst du frühstücken?
Eine Unternehmerfamilie führt
die Sticktradition bis heute weiter.
Caroline Forster
gehört zur vierten Generation.
Mit Ehemann Patrick
und der achtmonatigen Tochter Elin
wohnt sie mitten in der Altstadt.
Du hast Spass, was?
Kleines Mädchen.
Ciao, Spatz. Etwas Lippenstift ...
Wenn die Mutter arbeiten geht,
bleibt Elin bei der Nanny.
Caroline wurde als jüngstes
von vier Kindern
in die Familiendynastie Forster
hineingeboren.
Als Co-CEO trägt sie ihre
Kollektionen für Damenunterwäsche
in die ganze Welt hinaus.
Mit spitzenmässigem Erfolg.
(Englisch) Hallo, wie geht's?
- Gut, danke.
Ah, drei.
Die Britin Sian Thomas
ist Kreativchefin bei Triumph.
Im Archiv der Firma Forster Rohner
sucht sie nach neuen Inspirationen.
Dieser Duft, ich liebe ihn.
Der Designerin fallen
zwei unscheinbare Schachteln auf.
(Lachend) Can we have a look inside?
Oh, ich bin zu klein.
Das ist der Unterschied
zwischen uns Briten und Schweizern.
Schweizer sind sehr höflich.
Wir weniger.
Das ist echt ein Schatz, ja.
Unglaublich.
Braut Pippa Middleton
zog in Stickereien von Forster Rohner
alle Blicke auf sich.
Diese Kreation
schrieb gar Weltgeschichte.
Auch da: Wir haben natürlich
nicht direkt geliefert,
sondern einer Designerin.
Für First Lady Michelle Obama war
bei der Amtseinsetzung ihres Mannes
nur das Beste gut genug:
Kreationen aus St. Gallen.
Hier lagern sozusagen
die Kronjuwelen des Unternehmens.
Über 600'000 textile Muster,
zusammengetragen
innerhalb eines Jahrhunderts.
Ich selbst liebe das Archiv.
Nur schon, wenn man reinkommt.
Sian sagte, als sie reinkam:
"Es riecht so gut."
Für mich ist es genau dasselbe.
Es ist der Geruch nach alten
Büchern, wie in einer Bibliothek.
Das ist super.
* Sanfte, leichtfüssige Klänge *
Alle grossen Namen der Haute Couture
haben mit den St. Galler Spitzen
gearbeitet.
Es gibt noch weitere Schätze.
Das sind Kleider meiner Grossmutter
väterlicherseits, Doris Forster.
Sie kriegte sie von ihrem ...
Ich nehme einfach eins raus.
... von ihrem Ehemann gesponsert.
Denn sie
hatten sehr viele Anlässe zu Hause.
Wenn Kunden nach St. Gallen kamen,
kamen sie zu ihnen nach Hause.
Und sie dinierten dort.
Das ist wunderbar.
Incredible.
Das ist von 1957.
Das ist guipure superpose,
die luxuriöseste Stickerei.
Das könnte passen.
Ich kann nicht glauben,
dass du das noch nie angezogen hast.
Ich würde mich da reinquetschen.
Ja, irgendwie ...
... habe ich viel Respekt davor.
Irgendwann,
irgendwann ziehe ich das mal an.
Kilimandscharo, Kenia.
Agrarforscher Hans Rudolf Herren
und Andreas Schriber,
Leiter von Biovision,
sind unterwegs zum Victoriasee.
In Kisumu heisst es vorerst: warten.
Sofort versucht sich der 71-jährige
Herren mit der Welt zu verbinden.
Mit einem seiner drei Handys.
Ich habe morgen, oder übermorgen,
ein Meeting mit der Regierung,
das man organisieren sollte.
Am Freitag habe ich geschrieben
und angerufen -
und jetzt ist Dienstagmorgen,
aber noch nichts da.
Es braucht viel Geduld
und Diplomatie.
Manchmal möchte man lieber auf den
Tisch klopfen, aber das geht nicht.
Hans Rudolf Herren
ist im Wallis aufgewachsen.
Er lernte Landwirt
und wurde später Agrarforscher.
In Afrika bewahrte er
mit biologischer Schädlingsbekämpfung
Millionen von Menschen
vor dem Hungertod
und wurde mit den renommiertesten
Preisen ausgezeichnet.
* Leise Trommelklänge *
Ankunft am Victoriasee,
dem grössten Binnengewässer Afrikas.
Hier lebte und arbeitete
Hans Rudolf Herren 26 Jahre lang.
Seine Forschung
sollte Hunger und Armut bekämpfen.
Bis heute
ist er vom afrikanischen Kontinent
und der Widerstandskraft
der Menschen hier beeindruckt.
Sie können mit den Schwierigkeiten
umgehen, fröhlich sein.
Das ist faszinierend.
In unserer Welt wären die meisten
unter solchen Umständen
wohl ständig traurig.
Die Forschungsstation icipe Odhiambo
ist das Ziel.
Zeyaur, wie geht's?
- Danke, und dir?
Gut, danke. Geht's dir gut?
- Very good, yes.
Begrüsst werden die Schweizer vom
Direktor der Station, Zeyaur Khan.
Herren war sein Vorgänger, er leitete
dieses Institut neun Jahre lang.
Morning.
Ich bin neugierig, von Ihrem Mentor
habe ich viel Gutes über Sie gehört.
Hier erforschte Herren,
wie Pflanzenschädlinge ohne Einsatz
von Chemie zu bekämpfen sind.
So was machte ich auch viel,
als ich Student war.
Millionen Insekten ausgezählt.
Ich weiss, wie das geht -
das ist sehr anstrengende Arbeit.
Hans Rudolf Herrens Durchbruch
war in den 80er-Jahren.
Damals zerstörte ein Schädling
die Maniok-Pflanze.
Maniok ist in Afrika
ein Grundnahrungsmittel,
es drohte eine Katastrophe.
Das ist der Bösewicht: Die Schmier-
laus liess den Maniok absterben.
Diese Schlupfwespe
fand Herren in Paraguay.
Das Insekt bohrt die Schmierlaus an,
legt Eier ab,
die Larven fressen den Wirt auf.
Nach vielen Widerständen konnte
der Nützling nach Afrika importiert
und dort gezüchtet werden.
Das bisher grösste
Schädlingsbekämpfungsprogramm
ohne Einsatz von Chemie
war erfolgreich
und rettete Millionen von Menschen
vor dem Verhungern.
Als erster Schweizer erhielt Herren
den Welternährungspreis.
Es folgte der Right Livelihood Award,
der alternative Nobelpreis.
Die Familie war oft an seiner Seite.
Auch die Mächtigen ehrten ihn:
Bill Clinton,
Prince Charles,
Margaret Thatcher und der ehemalige
US-Präsident Jimmy Carter.
Aber biologische Schädlingsbekämpfung
sei für Chemiekonzerne
nicht lukrativ genug.
Und warum?
Weil wir Methoden vorschlagen,
die nicht
mit der Businesswelt korrelieren.
Sondern eher mit der Natur.
Die Natur zu uns ziehen ...
Erst mal die Natur verstehen
und sie dann für eine natürliche
Problemlösung einsetzen.
Den Planeten, die Menschheit,
auf eine andere,
eine nachhaltige Spur bringen.
Ein Feierabendbier
mit Andreas Schriber,
dem Leiter der Stiftung Biovision,
die Herren gegründet hat.
Die beiden arbeiten eng zusammen.
Hans lebt einfach
24 Std. sieben Tage die Woche
für seine Überzeugung.
Da gibt es keine Arbeitszeiten,
kein Arbeitsreglement,
keine Bürozeiten.
Aber wir haben eine Aufgabe.
Wir haben uns mit Biovision
eine Aufgabe gegeben -
oder auch
mit dem Millenium-Institut.
Die Welt zu retten, fast.
Aber nicht alleine.
Wir müssen Leute reinholen oder mit
Leuten mit derselben Idee arbeiten.
Das machst du doch auch so.
- Ja, sicher.
Heute berät Hans Rudolf Herren
Regierungen
beim Aufbau
einer nachhaltigen Landwirtschaft.
Im Fünfsternehotel in Hanoi
wohnen nicht nur Hotelgäste,
auch der Direktor
lebt hier mit seiner Familie.
Zähne putzen.
- Okay.
In 10 Min. müssen wir los.
Anzug und Krawatte
gehören zum seriösen Auftritt.
Ich finde es in einem Stadthotel
wie diesem hier anständig,
eine Krawatte zu tragen.
Manche sagen,
ich sei etwas konservativ.
Aber das ist schon gut.
Das ginge schon einfacher,
wenn du die Schuhe öffnen würdest.
Tschau, mach's gut!
Sohn Achita,
der nur Aschi gerufen wird, ist elf.
Jeden Morgen bringt ihn ein Bus
in die englischsprachige Schule.
Dann verrät Simon Rindlisbacher
sein kleines Geheimnis.
Das ist mein Lieblingsthema.
Ich mag Fahnen.
neben die vietnamesische habe ich
die Schweizer Flagge gehängt.
Es hat mich noch niemand gefragt,
wieso.
Es ist etwas mein Geheimnis.
Ich bin General Manager, deshalb
nehme ich mir diese Freiheit.
Es ist ein Land,
das irgendwie mir gehört.
Meine Mutter ist aus Venezuela,
mein Vater ist Schweizer.
Aber die Schweiz ist unsere Heimat.
Eine andere Heimat ist Thailand,
eine andere Venezuela.
Es ist multikulti.
Caroline Forster
ist Chefin von Inter-Spitzen.
Textile Kreationen
für Damenunterwäsche
treffen hier
auf futuristische Spielereien.
Ein BH mit LED-Lämpchen.
Das ist auch der Sinn der Sache.
Dass sich das befruchtet.
Der traditionelle Einsatz
der Stickerei
und die technischen Textilien
oder der technische Einsatz
der Stickerei.
Der Sticksaal
ist das Herzstück des Unternehmens.
Hier entstehen edle Kreationen
für Lingerie, Haute Couture
und Pret-a-porter.
Ein exklusiver Einblick.
Vieles darf nicht gezeigt werden
und ist Geschäftsgeheimnis.
Mit ihrem ältesten Bruder Emanuel
teilt sich Caroline die Leitung
der Forster Rohner Gruppe.
Seine Stickereien werden von Dior,
Chanel und Prada verarbeitet.
Der Textiler fasst alles an.
Das muss man.
Man muss auch schauen, wie es fällt.
So was ...
Das fällt so gut - wie es spielt.
Das ist super.
Emanuel ist das älteste von vier
Kindern, Caroline das jüngste.
Sie sind
die vierte Forster-Generation.
Vater Ueli
war der Patron der Traditionsfirma.
Du warst eigentlich ...
... der Kronprinz. Schon etwas.
Doch.
- Ich habe einfach hier gearbeitet.
Ich musste mich dann einordnen
im Ganzen.
Weil ich die Zweite war, die kam.
Die grosse Herausforderung ist:
Design ist immer wieder neu.
Immer wieder neu, neu, neu.
Immer wieder anders.
So müssen wir uns
auch immer wieder neu ausrichten.
Gehen wir runter?
- Ja, gut.
Gut, super.
Ich lasse das einfach hier, gut?
Wer Erfolg haben will,
muss in Bewegung bleiben -
das gilt auch in Hanoi.
Schon wieder
ziemlich unordentlich hier.
Gut, das ist eigentlich okay.
Nicht so schmutzig.
Ich bin hands-on.
Ich gehe überall reinschauen.
Und zwischendurch erschrecken sie,
wenn du reinläufst.
Aber ich scheue mich nicht,
reinzugehen.
Das ist das security office.
Everything okay? Xin chao.
- Yeah.
Hier haben wir Bildschirme
von jedem Stock.
Jede Kamera wird überwacht.
So sehen wir, dass alles läuft.
Es ist interessant,
ich kann schauen, ob sie
an der Rezeption richtig arbeiten.
Im Ballroom sind momentan
etwas viele Personen.
Gehen wir kurz schauen,
ob es dort in Ordnung ist.
Der Saal wurde
für ein elegantes Diner gebucht.
Ich schaue es kurz auf Fehler durch.
Fehler im Menü sind etwas peinlich.
Dann schaue ich auch,
ob alles sauber aussieht.
Aber es ist kein grosses Bankett,
knapp 100 Personen.
Für uns ist das nicht so gross.
Aber schön, sieht gut aus.
* Romantische Klavierklänge *
Gehen wir in der Küche schauen,
wie es läuft.
Seit dem Abschluss
der Hotelfachschule
arbeitet Rindlisbacher
in Südostasien.
Seinem Blick entgeht nichts.
Das ist nicht so schön.
Da fehlt mir die Liebe.
Das ist nicht schönes Gemüse.
Das kommt aufs Buffet,
das sehen die Leute.
Es muss schön aussehen.
Chef, guten Abend.
Dieser Korb mit dem Gemüse:
Bitte schauen Sie,
dass das Gemüse perfekt ist.
Etwas mehr Gemüse,
es muss gut aussehen.
Okay, okay.
- Danke, Chef.
Für mich ist er die Nummer 1
in der Küche.
Als Executive Sous-Chef
ist er Manager
und sollte das vertragen.
Jetzt haben wir keine Zeit mehr, um
zu spielen - es muss gemacht werden.
Dann wechselt Rindlisbacher
seinen Hut
und wird vom Hoteldirektor zum Vater.
Hoi. Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Hattest du es gut in der Schule?
- Hm?
War es gut in der Schule?
- Ja.
Seid ihr zu spät gekommen?
- Nein.
Was habt ihr gemacht in der Schule?
- Mathe.
Und, war gut?
Der viel beschäftigte Agraringenieur
Hans Rudolf Herren
reist fast jeden Monat
von den USA in die Schweiz.
Nebst Geschäftsterminen steht jeweils
auch ein Besuch bei seiner Mutter
in Monthey auf dem Programm.
Es ist offen.
Hallo, Mami.
So, wie geht's?
- So wie's geht.
So wie's geht? Gut.
Emma Herren ist 98
und hat vier Kinder.
Hans Rudolf ist ihr einziger Sohn.
Per Skype haben die beiden
regelmässig Kontakt.
Aber jetzt
macht das iPad der Mutter Probleme.
Das Gerät selbst ... Ich glaube,
das ist sechs Jahre alt.
Noch älter.
- Oder noch älter.
"Software-Aktualisierung".
Jetzt mal: "Updates suchen".
Dann muss man schauen ...
Ich habe das alles durchgelesen,
aber ...
Du hast sicher nicht alles gelesen.
Sonst hätte ich gesagt:
aus dem Fenster damit.
Nein, wir können auch mit WhatsApp.
Herrens Vater
ist schon seit Jahren tot.
Er war Verwalter einer Tabakplantage.
Mit seinem Sohn
war er überaus streng.
Es werde nie was Rechtes aus ihm,
sagte der Vater.
Vater hatte immer
eine negative Einstellung.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich etwas
machen wollte, war es nicht gut.
Ja.
Leider war der Alkohol halt ...
... sein grosser Freund.
Zu seinem Schaden.
Ich habe es einfach ignoriert.
Wenn er sagte, dass ich nicht
fähig sei, etwas zu unternehmen ...
Ich wusste, woher das kam.
Es war ein bisschen
wie Regen auf den Federn.
Er ist wirklich ...
Ich konnte immer auf ihn zählen.
Er ist ein guter Mensch.
Er geht wohl schon.
Barbara ist auch dort.
(Leise) Sie geht dann nach Belgien
und geht dann ...
Frauen sollen auch als Mütter
berufstätig sein können.
Dafür engagiert sich
Caroline Forster.
Hallo!
Ist meine Schwester hier?
Sie ist oben.
- Oben? Sehr gut.
Hoi, du.
Darum hat sie diese Kinderkrippe
mit ihrer Schwester gegründet.
Wir konnten so weit alles erledigen,
es ist nichts mehr offen.
Die Revision ist durch.
Schwester Ariane hat drei Kinder
und arbeitet als Juristin Teilzeit.
Ich sehe es jetzt selbst mit Elin.
Seit diesen acht Monaten merke ich,
welch organisatorische
Herausforderung das ist.
Und auch, welche Kraft das braucht,
das zu vereinbaren.
Nichtsdestotrotz bin ich der
Meinung, dass es möglich sein muss,
zu arbeiten
und auch Karriere zu machen
und gleichzeitig ein Elternteil
zu sein.
Für dieses Ziel arbeiten die beiden
Schwestern hier ehrenamtlich.
Den Willen,
die Gesellschaft mitzugestalten,
hat Caroline auch von ihrer Mutter
mit auf den Weg bekommen.
Die ehemalige FDP-Ständerätin
Erika Forster ist 75
und immer noch sehr aktiv.
Hallo.
- Hallo, wie lebst du?
Gut, gut.
- Das freut mich.
Was machst du?
- Ich schreibe, wie immer.
Du solltest hier
noch unterschreiben.
Okay.
- Ich mache es kurz fertig, gut?
Soll ich Kaffee machen?
- Gern, das wäre sehr lieb. Danke.
Aber nicht,
dass du zu lange bleibst?
Wie ich dich kenne,
gehst du bald wieder.
Auch die Mutter hat viel zu tun.
Ich finde es immer noch spannend,
etwas zu tun.
Die Pension ist nichts für mich.
So, jetzt ist es fertig.
Machen wir zu.
Politikerin und Mutter - Erika
Forster machten beide Rollen Freude.
Möchtest du auch einen?
- Nein, danke.
Als extrem präsente,
liebevolle Mutter.
Ja, gut. Ja.
Ich würde sagen: "Das stimmt."
Ich hatte wirklich
Verständnis für euch.
Ja, nein, und ...
- Oder wie soll ich sagen?
Ich bin nicht schnell
zu verschrecken.
Mit diesen vier
hatte man es immer lustig.
Natürlich musste ich
ab und zu sagen: "So nicht."
Klar,
man muss ihnen etwas beibringen.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen ...
- Extrem liebevoll.
Ich war sehr gern
mit meiner Mutter zusammen.
Hast du alles?
Mein Ziel ist, dass Elin auch mal
so von mir spricht.
Dann habe ich alles richtig gemacht.
Das ist ein schönes Kompliment.
- Es ist so.
Bis heute steht die Mutter der
Tochter mit Rat und Tat zur Seite.
Für Südostasien
hat Simon Rindlisbacher
ein aussergewöhnliches Hobby.
Ihn lockt das Glatteis.
Wir spielen nur zum Spass,
das ist besser mit Helm.
Wir sind
nicht mehr so die Superstars.
Ich zumindest nicht.
* Dynamische Klänge *
To the left, come on!
Jetzt ist fertig.
Ich bin auch fertig.
Nach fast 90 Min. auf dem Eis
merke ich es schon:
Das sind alles Jungspunde,
ausser einer oder zwei.
Aber ich muss noch etwas kämpfen.
Okay, last goal wins!
Mit seinen Sportsfreunden abzuhängen,
gehört zum Trainingsprogramm.
Sie sind Expats wie Simon.
... the hockey stick on the back.
- And a baby in the middle.
Es ist super, einfach hier zu sein.
Es etwas zu geniessen,
zusammen zu sein.
Der Lärm und alles ...
Das ist gut.
Es sind einfach Trottel.
Auch Eishockeyspieler, halt.
Es ist schon schön,
sie sind ganz anders.
Ich schalte aus,
rede nicht vom Beruf ...
Nicht immer ganz anständig sein,
mal ein Schlawiner sein -
das gehört auch dazu.
200 km von San Francisco entfernt
liegt das Capay Valley.
Es ist ein kalifornisches Weingebiet.
Auch der gelernte Landwirt
Hans Rudolf Herren baut Wein an,
und er züchtet Schafe.
* Er lacht. *
Die haben's schön.
Die fressen den ganzen Tag ...
Sicherheitstrakt,
weg von den Kojoten.
Deshalb sperren wir sie nachts ein.
Das ist gut, schön.
Natürlich gedeiht hier alles
ohne Einsatz von Chemie.
Eine Solaranlage produziert
mehr Strom, als der Hof benötigt.
Herrens Ehefrau Barbara ist Biologin.
Sie hat sich
auf Wildbienen spezialisiert.
Zusammen haben sie drei Kinder.
Das Paar hat sich vor 38 Jahren
an der Universität kennengelernt.
Unsere Studien
waren nicht so wichtig.
Wir arbeiteten
in einem schäbigen Wohnwagen
auf der Forschungsstation
in Berkeley.
Er mochte mich erst nicht so,
ihm gefiel gar nicht,
dass ich das Velo mit ins Büro nahm.
Eines Tages
steht ein Velo in meinem Büro.
Und jemand hat sich eingenistet
im Büro nebenan.
"Wer ist das wieder?"
Anfangs schaute ich etwas quer rein.
Aber das dauerte
natürlich nicht lange.
Übrigens hat Herren
auch als Winzer Erfolg.
Sein Wein wurde
mit einer Goldmedaille ausgezeichnet.
We haven't thought about that.
- Yeah.
In Paris ist Caroline Forster
schon frühmorgens
mit ihrem Musterkoffer unterwegs.
Vier Geschäftstermine
stehen auf ihrer Agenda.
Bevor sie im Familienunternehmen
eingestiegen ist,
hat sie hier in Paris
zehn Monate bei Chantelle gearbeitet.
Die Geschäftsbeziehungen sind eng.
Ca va?
- Merci beaucoup.
Intern lachen sie mich aus,
weil ich die Kollektion so verpacke.
Wir haben lange daran gearbeitet -
sie ist mein Kapital.
Es wäre blöd, sie nicht zu schützen.
Es nervt mich einfach,
wenn sie Eselsohren kriegt.
Das ist schön.
Ja, das seid ihr.
Das ist Inter-Spitzen,
sie haben die Stickerei gemacht.
Hat Inter-Spitzen
auch in dieser Saison
den Geschmack der Kundin getroffen?
Ich bin gespannt,
ob es gefällt oder nicht.
Sandrine weiss sehr genau, was sie
will und sucht entsprechend aus.
Il est tres luxueux.
Die Erfahrung hat gezeigt:
Schweizer Qualität kommt an.
Für uns ist es ein wichtiger Moment.
Ich habe eine Riesenfreude -
ich liebe den Moment, in dem
ich die fertigen Produkte sehe.
Es ist einfach cool.
Man könnte das
mit etwas Pflegeleichtem mischen.
Ja, ich denke, ich hab's verstanden.
Tout ca, je peux vous le laisser.
Die Zusammenarbeit ist sehr gut.
Wir sind sehr effizient,
sehr schnell.
Wir verstehen uns,
haben eine ähnliche Kultur.
Unser gemeinsames Verständnis
ist sehr hilfreich.
Je vous dis a bientot, Caroline,
merci.
In der Schweiz
sind es drei Küsschen.
Oui, c'est ca.
Bis bald und danke.
Jetzt müssen wir uns beeilen.
Die nächste Kundin wartet bereits.
Hallo. Der Koffer ist schwer.
In Kalifornien zeugen Auszeichnungen
von den grossen Erfolgen
von Hans Rudolf Herren.
Als Forscher
hat er fast alles erreicht.
Und doch spürt seine Frau bisweilen
den Schatten seiner Vergangenheit.
Er hatte es nicht leicht
mit seinem Vater.
Er musste lernen, zu überleben.
Schon früh war ihm bewusst,
dass er allein ist.
Wenn er ein Feld pflügen musste
und irgendwo etwas Gras war,
kritisierte ihn sein Vater.
Wenn er nichts sagte, war es okay.
Es ist hart,
kein positives Feedback zu bekommen.
So hat Hans Rudolf Herren
schon früh gelernt,
sich von der Meinung anderer
zu lösen.
Ich machte einfach immer,
was ich für richtig hielt.
Ob rundherum gesagt wurde,
es ginge nicht, sei nicht gut,
war mir egal.
Ich sagte: "Du wirst schon sehen.
Ich mache jetzt mal."
* Gemächliche Klänge *
An sich und seine Fähigkeiten glauben
trotz widriger Umstände -
das war Herrens Weg zum Erfolg.
Wie lange dauert es
bis zum Flughafen?
30, 35 Min.
- Ah nur, okay.
Der Tag in Paris ist fast zu Ende.
Wo sieht sich die Geschäftsfrau
in 20 Jahren?
Meine Güte, in 20 Jahren ...
Das ist ein unheimlich langer
Zeitraum in unserem Business.
Ich habe ...
acht Neffen und Nichten.
Dazu kommt Elin
oder vielleicht auch sonst wer.
Das ist eigentlich
auch nicht so wichtig.
Einfach, dass es weitergeht.
Abgesehen davon: In 20 Jahren
bin ich ziemlich sicher noch dabei.
Ja.
Ihre reichhaltigen Erfahrungen
wird sie dann wohl
an die fünfte Forster-Generation
weitergeben können.
In Hanoi geniesst Simon Rindlisbacher
einen freien Tag
mit Frau June und den beiden Söhnen
Aschi und Ariya.
Mir gibt Zeit mit der Familie
einen wahnsinnigen Ausgleich.
Das konnte ich mir
lange nicht vorstellen,
wollte immer allein Karriere machen,
aber jetzt ist das wunderschön.
Wenn ich mit der Familie bin,
versuche ich,
nicht immer am Telefon zu sein
und meine Mails zu checken.
Das sind meine Vorsätze.
Die Familie
lebt seit eineinhalb Jahren hier.
Vorher war Bangkok ihr Zuhause.
So.
Unser favourite cafe, eh? Xofa.
Wir haben uns
per Zufall in Bangkok getroffen.
Nach der Arbeit gab es einen Platz,
auf dem sich
Ausländer und Thais mischten.
Sie kam von ihrem Geschäft,
ich von meinem.
Dann klaute sie meinen Tisch.
Als ich ihm das erste Mal begegnete,
spürte ich:
Er ist sehr höflich und warm.
Wie soll ich sagen?
Er ist eine warme Person.
Sie ist halt schon eine Herzige.
Dann haben wir uns
regelmässig getroffen
und sind dann zusammengekommen.
Und dann kam auf einmal Aschi.
Er ist so schüchtern wie Papi.
Gell? Shy as the Papi.
Seine Kinder würde Simon
gerne in der Natur aufwachsen sehen,
aber in einer Stadt wie Hanoi
ist das unmöglich.
Gehst du innen?
Nicht an der Strasse.
Du musst die Hand geben,
weil wir auf der Strasse sind!
Es beginnt mit der Schule:
Ein Schulbus holt Aschi.
Er kann nicht allein gehen.
Und das ist das Problem.
Wir können nicht draussen spielen.
Da er ein gutes Jobangebot
bekommen hat,
zieht die Familie nun in die Schweiz.
Wir wollen nicht weg, aber es
ist einfach eine super Möglichkeit,
jetzt wieder
zurück in die Schweiz zu gehen.
Sonst wären wir schon
zwei, drei Jahre hier geblieben.
June hat bereits ein Jahr
in der Schweiz verbracht.
Ja, wenn mein Mann und unsere Söhne
Schweizerdeutsch sprechen,
verstehe ich,
worüber sie sich unterhalten.
Sie versteht zu viel,
das ist das Problem.
Jetzt müssen wir einfach gehen,
kommt!
* Hupen *
Das ist gefährlich.
So.
Ich bin gespannt und freue mich,
in die Schweiz zurückzukehren.
Für mich ist es auch sehr wichtig,
dass mein Mann dort
wieder einen guten Job haben kann.
Nach 16 Jahren Südostasien
wird Simon Rindlisbacher
Campus-Manager
an einer Schweizer Hotelfachschule.
Wir haben grosse Vorfreude.
Ich glaube,
die Eingliederung wird einfach.
Vielleicht vermissen wir das Ausland
auch nach kurzer Zeit.
Aber ich glaube, der neue Job,
das neue Abenteuer
mit der neuen Wohnung,
mit neuen Leuten und alten Freunden,
nahe der Familie zu sein ...
Ich glaube, das wird fantastisch.
So hat auch Simon Rindlisbacher
mit viel Leidenschaft,
Energie und Disziplin
seinen Weg zu
einem erfolgreichen Leben gefunden.